ｗ
ファイナルファンタジー15の影響で
全身真っ黒です
はじめしゃちょーです。
はいというわけで皆さん、トントン相撲って知ってますか？
あの、箱を土俵にして
箱の上に人の形をした紙を二つ折りにして置いて
二つね
二つ置いて
トントントントンしてどっちが先に倒れるかっていう
トントン相撲っていう遊びがあるんですけでも
今回はそれを超巨大バージョンでふとやりたくなったので
もう太陽が落ちそうなんですけど今からやります
いやーまじでちょっとホント太陽沈みそうなんすよ
結構やばいよね？笑えない速度で速いもう
段ボールめちゃくちゃたくさん準備したので
時間ないんで
なるべく超巨大のトントン相撲作り出して
大人のトントン相撲
なんかエロく聞こえますね
大人のトントン相撲やっていこうと思います
ではいこう
( ^)o(^ )
*笑*
完成しましたあああ
というわけでお互いの機体が完成したので紹介していきましょう
まずはのりくん
のり：僕の機体はですね
のり：なんといったって軽さを重視しました
はじめ：これまたどういうあれで作ったんですか？
のり：やっぱ僕小さいじゃないですか結構
168cmしかないんで
軽い機体を目指して作りました
はじめ：軽量タイプね
のり：軽量タイプになってきました
というわけで私の機体はこちらです
のり：もう最後の方言えてないｗ
えーこれはですねもうふんだんにね体の大きさを利用して
段ボールの割合を考えずにほぼ8割がた僕が使って作ったロボットです
足腰がしっかりしてるのと
長い腕のミーチで確実に敵を潰すというスタイルで作りました
というわけでですね
専用のスタジアムも準備してあるので
この土俵で今から実際に戦ってきたいと思います
のり：あっ顔が
おおお
ウィーーン　ガシャーン
はっはっはっはっ
はじめ：立ちましたねー
のり：立ちました
やべっ
あ、腕がやべー
腕が
ちょっと待って
足もやばい　ちょっと待って
やばい
ちょっとタンマ
あーあーアーーッ♂
おおーー
*笑*
よっしゃ！
ハッハッハッハッハッハッハッハッ
どうだー！これだ！
選手入場
構え
はっけよい
のこった！
のり：え、え、えー
やったああああ
やったぞ！
落ちないよね？
痛ッ
あー！